chance to help local organization the
chef jeff project
transform lives through food that starts
tomorrow and every saturday at a pop-up
in north las vegas
rocky thea stopped by to learn more
changing lives through food so chef jeff
what does that mean
exactly well you know we use culinary
arts food as a therapeutic
and transformative tool to help our
young people
overcome some of the trauma and issues
they had in their life
a lot of our young people are formerly
incarcerated like myself who spend 10
years in federal prison
where i learn how to bake and i learn
how to cook so the chef jeff project
really isn't about making these young
people chefs are cooked
it's about getting them to pivot getting
them to decriminalize getting them to
change their value systems
and go out into the workforce and learn
how to compete for jobs out there in the
world
so i've been here a little while now and
i've seen you you know
giving them a good little talking to as
we're going around but that's that's
what it's all about discipline is about
life skills so what's the experience
like for the kids well you know i'm a
tough love chef you know i'm
straightforward
because my job as the chef and the
founder of the chef chef project is to
train these kids
of what they're going to expect when
they go out in the workforce here i
tolerate a lot
because this is training when they leave
the chef chef project they go on the
strip they go downtown
or whatever job they decide to do those
folks out there they don't want to hear
a lot of stuff they want to know can you
perform
are you an asset versus a liability so
that's my job is to make sure they leave
out here
with the work tools necessary to be
employed that is incredible and i want
to talk to one of your one of your guys
ezekiel because he is
certain you have turned him certainly
into an asset he's over here doing all
the things that i can't do in the
kitchen okay ezekiel can i can i talk to
you for a second
so how how has the chef jeff project
changed your life the championship
project has changed my life in many ways
you know
uh i always was a hard head you know up
in the streets you know doing all type
of stuff you know and i always had the
gift of cooking you know
even when i got locked up at spring
mountain i got sent up there and i was
in the hip program in a
hospitality program cooking and when i
got out you know
i was just trying to better my life you
know i was working at restaurants
but i didn't really get all the
experience i needed so i
called yet and they put me in this
program and honestly man i've been
taking off here man
i ain't never baked in my life you know
i just been doing everything that
you know that's that i know i really can
do inside you know
so it's been a blessing so you've always
had the tools but now they're just even
sharper
yeah they're even sharper you know more
better that's beautiful thank you
ezekiel so chef jeff
here every every saturday we have a
pop-up people can come out and help you
celebrate
these young lives success so how can
people help yeah so between uh
from eight o'clock to 11 o'clock we sell
beignets
chicory coffee and jambalaya it's in
honor of new orleans louisiana
where my folks are from so you come out
here and meet the young people
we accept donations and all the help we
can get from the community at the
chefchairproject.org
wow this is incredible i'm ready to eat
you guys you guys got me
oh i'll yeah it back to you guys
jambalaya wow we're all starving here in
the newsroom
i